something a lot of you guys don't know
about me is that i'm a huge fan of
electronic dance music and i've got some
djing skills under my belt and i
recently got my numark ns7s back but
they don't work on big sur or catalina
so i'm buying some crappy old 2012
macbook pro so i can install snow
leopard and run serato itch and just
keep things simple having said that this
episode of what if was amazing oh my god
dude this episode was legit dude it blew
the episode of doctor strange out of the
water up until this point the episode of
doctor strange was the best episode
right like we can we can all just just
nod your heads write anybody in the
comments who says no this episode was
better they're full of hoo-ha jews we
can all just agree the doctor strange
episode was the best one but this one
was nuts and here's a funny thing here
this was about the most faithful
adaptation of the original age of ultron
storyline that marvel gabe was stranded
in that story ultron never got the
infinity stones and never went into the
multiverse the whole basis behind that
story was basically ultron in the future
took over the body of vision and the
present and then just use it to spawn a
litany of ultron robots and then
basically conquer the modern day like
quite literally it's like the most
depressing thing ever quite literally
the story opens up and captain america
is just devastating he's just sitting in
a corner his shield is broken his spirit
is totally destroyed and then like they
rescue peter parker he makes some
offhanded remark and then they find nick
fury and then they all basically get
killed when they go into the future and
then wolverine screws out the timeline i
know it seems kind of weird you'll find
the whole series over comics explain
although i might remaster it now that i
think about it the important thing here
is this this episode was the tits but
the ending has me just baffled man the
ending has me just baffled in terms of
what's gonna happen just baffled right
it has to be so baffled in terms of
what's gonna happen in the future of the
mcu
i have no idea what's gonna go on here
but
i've got some theories so here's the
thing for those of you guys who are
curious about the powers and the
abilities of the watcher we actually
have a video on that the origins and
powers of the watcher which will tell
you what his origin is and just how
powerful he is because this guy's pretty
op as you saw over the course of this
episode having said that let's get into
the theories about this whole thing so
the first question that i found myself
asking here is why does the watcher need
evil doctor strange right evil strange
we need to come up with a good name for
that guy right because evil doctor
strange is just too much right i mean
when captain america's history was
changed using a cosmic cube to make him
into a secret hydra agent in the comics
we called him stevel so we need
something like this with regards to evil
doctor strange right evil strange
strangel i don't know you guys are
creative come up with something but why
do they need this guy okay so there's a
couple ideas here first things first my
immediate thought is because that guy is
the only one that has enough power to
rival the ability or the the
capabilities of ultron with the infinity
stones and that kind of makes sense to a
degree but at the same time if that's
the case then it begs another question
because what we learned in this is that
contrary to everything we know in the
comics the infinity stones work across
the multiverse right so you can take the
infinity stones from one universe and
use them in another we know that from a
couple different circumstances the first
is that ultron entered into the realm of
the watcher which seemingly exists
outside of the multiverse or it's some
kind of secret place within the main
marvel cinematic universe however as
they were fighting they were jumping
through universes and at no point did
the power of ultron wane in any form or
fashion indicating the stones work in
other realities now i'm coming to this
from the perspective of the comics and
my thought here is it's not supposed to
work that way however different
multiverse different set of rules it's a
whole different ball game now right so
if that was the case why wouldn't the
watcher just go to an alternate reality
get his own infinity stones and then
fight ultron right so maybe it's
something bigger than that and that's
what leads me into this first theory
that the watcher kind of looks at the
role that ultron's playing what he's
doing in terms of just leading a cascade
of destruction across the multiverse
because that's what he says if that kind
of power is unleashed on the multiverse
it would just lead to a huge amount of
destruction so my thought my first
theory here is far-fetched and crazy as
it is is that the watchers getting with
that evil version of doctor strange
because he's the only one who knows how
to get in contact with a living tribunal
so they can basically do what they do in
the comics which is approach the
tribunal and say you have to do
something about this now before you guys
turn off this video right before you
guys are just like oh rob he's crazy in
the living room
hear me out for a second right so while
we're not exactly in the territory of
the comics per se
in marvel comics whenever there's a
massive calamity on a universal or
multiversal scale which creates an
imbalance which is to say a singular
person running amok across the universe
or the multiverse and disrupting the
natural order of things the living
tribunal will step in now oftentimes for
whatever reason mal doesn't really give
us an explanation you would think the
living tribunal would already know
because it literally knows everything
that's going on in the multiverse but
regardless they end up having to
approach the living tribunal and
essentially plead their case and they
say here's what's going on we need you
to do something about this now at that
point the living tribunal uses three
phases equity necessity and vengeance to
determine whether or not it needs to
actually do anything if the tribunal
judges against those who are pleading
their case and basically he's saying i
don't see a problem here uh good luck to
you i don't know what to tell you and
then he'll basically leave and do his
own thing if the living tribunal judges
in favor of them that's enough to just
halt whatever is that's going on right
it's usually enough power to stop
whatever's going on the only time that
didn't happen is when the beyonders
showed up and killed the living tribunal
right beyond that it can basically end
this now it's entirely possible that's
happening here do i think that's
actually happening no i think it's cool
and i think it's interesting truth to
tell i think the references we've seen
to the living tribunal over the course
of the marvel cinematic universe the
staff that was shown to us in doctor
strange the stone head that was shown to
us in the loki tv series i think those
are just designed to be easter eggs and
references right the idea of kind of
entertaining fan interest in the idea of
a living tribunal but not really
establishing that it actually exists the
second theory i have here is that the
watchers forming a kind of multiversal
team in the sense that this evil version
of doctor strange is going to be the
first person and presumably he's going
to grab other people now what evidence
do i have for this well truth to tell
whatever little scenes we got in the
what if series honestly there's not a
whole lot of evidence for this the
question you have to ask here though is
that evil doctor strange was powerful
enough to basically be a walking talking
infinity gauntlet right like his actions
led to the total destruction of his own
universe so while i wouldn't go as far
as to say the power he displayed
basically put him on par with an
infinity gauntlet right like that evil
version of doctor strange fighting
somebody with an infinity gauntlet and
evil dr strange wins we didn't really
see that but having the power to
basically destroy an entire universe
that's no small feat so the question you
would have to ask is given the power of
that evil version of doctor strange why
would the watcher need anybody else and
maybe he doesn't right maybe this is the
only guy he needs he's saying like i
need you not i need a team i need you
specifically because you're just that
damn powerful the other thing about this
is that if this is true this lends
credence to the theory that a lot of you
guys have that the doctor strange that
we're going to see in spider-man 3 is
not doctor strange right that if this
team-up were to happen let's say for
example the watcher breaks doctor
strange out of his prison and then in
turn he defeats evil ultron maybe the
watcher is incapacitated or knocked out
in the process and then he just bails
right just takes off to an alternate
reality while the watcher does say that
he sees everything we don't know if he
has a multiversal awareness meaning he's
aware of everything going on across the
multiverse all the time or is he doing
the equivalent of just flipping through
tv channels if he doesn't have a
multiversal cosmic awareness then if
this evil version of doctor strange just
takes off into the multiverse it's
looking for a needle in a haystack no
way he'd be able to find him in a
reasonable amount of time and so because
of that it would basically allow him to
kind of hide out in some alternate
reality the main marvel cinematic
universe and in the main marvel
cinematic universe he comes across that
version of doctor strange that we're
already familiar with who is basically
equal in power to the one that evil
doctor strange defeated in his own
reality and then now he takes his place
and then he's a little more devil may
care in terms of how he acts right a
little more reckless so on and so forth
and that's what leads him to messing
with the timeline in spider-man 3 and
everything pops off is it the perfect
theory not at all but i do think it
lends credence to the theory that a lot
of you all have now my final theory here
is one that i don't know if i'd say is a
little more practical but is one that i
think makes sense that it ties into the
idea of wanda and or king the conqueror
right that by whatever manner and
whatever means this final conflict with
ultravision basically ends up going on
between you know evil doctor strange and
watcher and vision or whatever who knows
how it plays out the important thing is
that possibly at some point near the end
of this conflict ultron vanishes just
disappears right and it's like where the
hell did he go nobody knows where he
went and the reason why is because in
the far-flung future kane the conqueror
came to the realization this guy's a
credible threat to the multiverse went
back in time basically either eliminated
tony stark or stopped tony stark from
creating ultron and because of that he
never exists another possibility here is
that in the midst of this battle kane
the conqueror sends his forces from the
tva to snatch up ultron and to bring him
to the future to use him for whatever
purposes he wants to use him for
remember ultron while he is sentient to
a degree is still a computer program
right he's still ran by an artificial
intelligence and it's well within the
capabilities of king to override that
intelligence right the technology
available to kane the conqueror is way
beyond anything that even iron man can
contend with he can kind of deal with it
to a degree but there's been multiple
times over the course of the comics when
iron man's like i mean i got nothing for
this right i mean this guy's technology
is just way beyond my level of
understanding right it's just that's how
far into the future he is so that's
entirely possible another possibility
here is that in the midst of this
conflict wanda just shows up out of
nowhere and just destroys ultron and
then leaves right because she's on her
journey to try to find her kids across
the multiverse that's one of the things
i love about this what if series
honestly anything's possible man and and
i got to be honest while it's very
difficult to come up with like a
definitive theory a definitive answer as
to what's actually going to happen over
the course of this entire series leading
to its conclusion most likely going into
spider-man 3 doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness i like that i can't find an
answer because it allows my brain to run
wild on theories right this is one of
those times when i'm kind of glad that
like there's no definitive endpoint
right we can't really see exactly where
this is going to go the mystery and
intrigue is awesome because truth to
tell this is what made the marvel
cinematic universe right you guys
remember those days when you would see
captain america shield pop up in iron
man thor's hammer land in new mexico
right you'd have nick fury who appeared
to tony stark and say you know i want to
talk to you about the avengers
initiative tony stark going and talking
to thunderbolt ross about the avengers
just all these little things here and
there right you know the sovereign
creating adam warlock and we don't know
what role he's gonna play in guardians
three like it's it's cool right this
mystery and intrigue is what made the
mcu the mcu and it's so awesome to see
the what if series is really just
leaning into that right just just
leaning into that just saying yeah man
this mystery this uh you know take your
best guess guys but who in the hell
knows what's gonna happen you gotta wait
till next week to find out i love it but
i absolutely love it truth tell i've
never been more excited about the mcu
than i am right now after this episode
right because you guys have to feel the
same way i do this is somehow going to
tie into doctor strange too there's no
way it can't there's no way you could
have a version of of ultron who
basically gets his vision body instead
of the avengers catching it and then
thanos shows up and just he cuts him in
half right and then in turn takes the
infinity stones for himself and then
goes into the multiverse and starts
wreaking havoc no
way this has no involvement in doctor
strange too you can't tell me it doesn't
right i mean we all know it will right
so the question is like how deep is this
gonna go i don't know maybe it's all
self-contained i have no idea regardless
this episode had so many just ridiculous
moments can we all just agree black
widow and hawkeye have never been so
badass in the mcu as they were in this
especially hawkeye man dude's got harry
potter's invisibility cloak right and
then like these ultron robots come to
sending down on him and they're like
where the hell is he and he's like he's
like surprise [ __ ] and then just start
shooting arrows all over the damn places
like damn son that was amazing and then
like thanos shows up right the portal
opens up
he's all like looking menacing and stuff
and ultron's like nope and then just bow
cuts him in half right and that's the
end of the thanos and he takes the
infinity stones this this episode had
great moments right it was it was it was
phenomenal one thing that i wish we
would have been able to see a little bit
more of is the death of the avengers
right the avenger is basically falling
at the hands of ultron i wish we could
have gotten a little more of that given
the entire breath of the episode i
understand why we didn't there was a lot
to cram in there so if they had maybe
another 15 minutes to work with they
definitely could have given it to us or
maybe another five or six minutes but
they're obviously trying to keep it
under 30 minutes right if they said hey
we're gonna give this one an extra five
minutes it would have been a cool five
minute scene right watching the avengers
just get destroyed by ultron having said
that they can largely kind of leave it
to us because we've seen the avengers
fight ultron in the ultron movie and
basically they were all kind of wrecked
initially so we sort of know how that
kind of thing unfolds but still it would
have been cool to see the avengers
killed having said that it's a great
time to be a fan guys it is a great time
to be a comic book fan with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace